hi guys I'm Eric Voss and to me get out
was the best film to come out so far
this year Jordan peels horror movie was
so perfectly crafted The Twilight Zone
style mystery and social commentary with
tons of little interesting details that
set up and pay off the big reveals and
one of the biggest twists came at the
end but we just found out that there's
an alternate ending that Jordan Peele
originally planned for the film's
closing moments now before I go any
further huge spoiler warning here
obviously if you haven't seen get out go
watch it he'll watch it again buy it on
blu-ray it's amazing don't let me ruin
the ending of this movie for you okay
quick recap get out ended with the hero
Chris learning the horrible truth that
the family of its girlfriend Rose is
using the bodies of healthy black people
to host the brains of sick or aging
white people but before he undergoes
this surgery Chris escapes the family
estate by killing roses
evil father brother and mother and in
the final scenes he faces off against
Rhoades choking her in the road but
ultimately deciding not to kill her
that's when a police car pulls up and as
he raises his hands everyone watching
feels this wave of dread about what's
going to happen next but then in
surprise it's not any police car it's an
airport police car driven by Rod Chris's
buddy who works with the TSA who tracked
him down on social media after he went
missing company you [ __ ] and
they drive off leaving Brian Williams
daughter bleeding to death on the side
of the road but now we know that this
victory wasn't the original ending the
alternate ending was way more of a
downer so rather than letting go of
roses neck in the last second Chris
continues choking her and roses evil
smile continues as the police car lights
flash on their faces and then the cops
in that car aren't rod they're two
actual cops who shout show me your hands
and tackle Chris to the ground then
after the scene cuts to black we find
ourselves in a prison visitation room
with rod talking to an incarcerated
Chris from behind glass Chris asks about
his dog Sid and rod pressures him for
more details about what happened trying
to build a legal defense for him but
Chris refuses probably knowing he has no
chance of fighting this saying only
I stopped them and then he stops the
Armitage family from hurting anyone else
then he hangs up and returns to his cell
block as Michael Abel's same hunting
entitled music plays so yeah this really
sucks for Chris but that was what Jordan
Peele originally intended he wanted this
movie to show that racism isn't over in
America saying this about it the ending
in that arrow was meant to say look you
you think they think race isn't an issue
well at the end we all know this is how
this movie would end right here however
Jordan Peele said that that was years
ago and that as the movie was being made
the deaths of people like Trayvon Martin
and Michael Brown brought the issue of
institutional racism in a criminal
justice system more to the forefront so
when test audiences wanted more from the
ending he decided to reshoot it actually
Jordan teal wrote several alternate
endings to get out including one that
featured rod but had another even
crazier dark ending but by the end rod
comes to the break in the gated
community finds his way in he's looking
for Chris and he sees Chris looking in a
window in our main street and because
Chris and Chris turns Dylan goes I
assure you I don't know who you're
talking ah
but ultimately Peele was happiest with
the theatrical ending the ending needed
to transform into something that gives
us a hero that gives us an escape gives
us a positive feeling when we leave this
movie there's nothing more satisfying
than seeing the audience go crazy yeah
my ride shows up and Peele is right this
ending is perfect it's a victory that
still makes us feel for moment at least
the horrifying real-world consequences
that Chris almost has to face like all
great horror directors Jordan field
knows that he can get mileage out of
hinting at a deep-rooted social anxiety
without fully showing his hand okay that
covers the get out alternate ending and
I'm going to go rewatch this movie
because there are so many layers of
meaning and subtle symbolism in this
movie it's brilliant and if you liked
this please hit like and share this
video with your friends and subscribe to
new rockstars this channel goes super
in-depth with all the cool stuff that
you missed in your favorite movies and
TV shows so check out some of our other
videos and if you really like this
channel you can contribute to us on
patreon thanks
much to all of our current patrons
especially Kelly hopper you can hit me
up on Twitter a TA box with any thoughts
you had about get out or follow new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates on our videos ok thanks for
watching bye
he